And I'm going to take you on a deep dive
into the MOOM
object system. MOOM to just give you an
introduction
is
MOO for LLMs. And MOO is inspired by
Pavel Curtis's LambdaMOO
that he developed at Xerox PARC. And uh
now there's a whole lot of designs here.
And uh
what we're going to dive into
is the object directory.
Object system. Okay.
Now,
MOOM inherits from a lot of different
really good ideas. And this will take
you on a tour of that. So,
uh the one important thing is MOOM
exists on the stage of a GitHub repo.
And GitHub Git
is over the
file system. [snorts]
And LLMs can read and edit the file
system, but Git adds parallel universes,
branching and merging. And GitHub adds
collaborative uh PRs
uh code reviews everything. So, that is
the stack that we're building on top of.
It's industrial strength. So, um now the
MOOM object system, how MOOM does
objects. Self-styled prototypes over the
file system with the LLM as the
universal resolver.
Promoted here from where the ideas were
first proven in the field, the Cauldron
Metaplan, Skill Security Architecture,
Directory as Object for the Opus Review,
Latent Space Inheritance, which
generalizes MOOM's inheritance model to
use the LLM as a universal resolver. The
most novel thing and the thing least
specific to the Cauldron. Cauldron is
just a skill for designing and so I'm
structuring design so that
you can work with a high-powered LLM to
design and then use lower-power models
to execute that design step-by-step. So,
now Self and Moons explains how Moons
uses a selfish-inspired
object system. The mechanism inherits
inherited self as an object-oriented
risk instruction set
via David Ungar's SOAR Smalltalk on RISC
project that he did before that. The
Lisp lineage flavors from MIT, Lisp
Machines, CLOS which was
when Common Lisp said, "Oh, we got all
these different object systems in Lisp
because you can roll your own and
there's many approaches. How can we make
an object system
for designing object systems, the
metaobject protocol?" So, Common Lisp
Object System is CLOS, which inherits
from Flavors and other things like
loops.
Uh and MOP is
it's kind of reifies how the it works.
It's something like this, reflective
power. Okay, so Gary Drescher, Scheme
lineage, has inspired this. He was uh
Marvin Minsky's PhD student and Leela
AI's advisor and we've discussed this
with him.
Piaget inspired Minsky who inspired
Drescher
who inspired Leela AI. This is all about
how do children learn
by playing and um
how can we
make an algorithm that does that? So,
but it was missing something and he
wrote it in Lisp
and uh Henry Minsky, my colleague at
Leela, who's
Marvin's son, wrote a Python
implementation, but all of them hit a
wall
of grounding and LLM grounding that
finally arrived. Okay, and I worked at
Sun on News, the News Toolkit at Turing
Institute with Arthur van Hoff on
Hyperlook
and Owen Densmore and David Rosenthal at
Sun who
at that time filed a patent for
looking at the Unix file system and
the shell and paths
as an multiple inheritance
object-oriented programming system just
like the one that was in move news that
we used to build TNT and then HyperLook
which was inspired by HyperCard.
Uh now
taking these ideas together is taking a
step back.
Then I did a prototype called Loom l l o
o o o m m that's kind of hard to spell.
But that was kind of to learn from and
then anthropic skills came along and I
realized I have to throw all that away
and start from scratch based on
anthropic skills because they are
awesome. They are composable.
And uh anyway, but I wanted to add
things to it to make it more powerful.
We've added like I think we're on like
10 extensions at this point and
counting. But the really important ones
are you can instantiate [snorts] a
skill. Okay? And we have multiple
inheritance which and like
prototype-based self-like multiple
inheritance. So you can have an instance
and it can inherit from several skills.
Uh then looking at the abomination that
is Microsoft COM
OLE, ActiveX
um type libraries even Mozilla looked at
that and said, "Hey, we need something
like that uh
XPCOM."
I've have used that. So also like even
companies like Macromedia looked at it
and said, "Hey, that's a great great
plugin system. We're going to make Boa."
There's like 12 different COM clones cuz
there is something to it.
Um and then character runes okay, that's
the idea
that like you can have a directory and
it has interfaces. It's like a COM
object, a OLE object, with multiple or
or Java object. And those interfaces are
uppercase character.yaml, uppercase
room.yaml that are declare it as
providing this interface. So, you can
look at a directory as both a character
and a room at the same time. Which is
great if you're doing like Pee-wee's
Playhouse and you want a talking room
that that
you know, remembers what happens in it.
There is there are applications of that
and we'll get to that. So, um naming and
structure as reflection. So, having a
consistent big Indian naming system
where you list the first thing for the
most important thing first and think how
are these going to alphabetically sort
so that related things are next to each
other
and implied
structure with shared prefixes. So, but
anyway,
listing a directory
is saying what interfaces and state do
you have. So, um and then the thing is
naming files and directories
as self-describing
big Indian
human and LLM friendly
klines. Klines are a concept from Marvin
Minsky
that are just like it's a token that
refers it's a string [snorts] you pull
that points to not just an idea but the
whole crowd of concepts around it and
what you were thinking of at the time.
So, the idea
is to have and define and just more
importantly reuse well-known words as
klines.
Uh and then you can just they're like
pointers to thought. So, so the
directory listing, the klines are the
file names and subdirectory names that
are pointers to files and
subdirectories.
The name explains itself. And then
something we borrow that's really
powerful is we'll write and Jamie
Dornbos invented this thing called
advertisements which sounds sort of
space.
Obscene but um
news called interests, event interests,
template for an event that you would
like to receive. And then what to do
when you get it. So, Sims advertisements
are on objects and it's the key to the
Sims plugin extensible
object system that allowed it to be so
successful by enabling
players to make their own objects and EA
to make their own expansion packs that
drop into the base game and just work
seamlessly. So,
uh successful way that their capability
announcements that I must stove and you
can cook on me and if you're hungry,
you'd probably want to do this. So, so
there an advertisement
is like a name of some function that you
can provide
but also uh
some parameters and some code that can
score how much you want to do based on
the context,
who you are, what relationships you have
to people, what your mood is. The toilet
advertises that it can move your bowels
if you need to go to the bathroom but
not if you don't. So, um the you know,
the bed you remember which side of the
bed to sleep on because you when you
sleep on that side of the bed,
that makes a relationship with the bed
that improves every time you do,
assuming you have decent experiences.
And that weighs the sleep in the
advertisement of that side of the bed.
Okay, so so you by doing it, you're
increasing the chances that you'll do it
later. So, um
anyway, so think of the LLM as having a
program counter of what to look at next.
And all these advertisements,
like whether they're a file name or a
directory name or something out there in
associative memory, you know, the fuzzy
search, the the vector store,
or here's the important thing, K lines
are greppable, okay? You can do very
cheap, very fast find me all
advertisement or all references to the
word advertisement in this or these 12
repos. So,
and the and the and then an LLM does
that to like what should I look at next
to add to my context.
So, we'll go over that, but latent space
inheritance, this is the great thing.
Oop, self then any
many languages, a lot of which were
inspired by it,
point to a set of parents. And those
parents are like made out of the same
thing, right? But the thing is with an
LLM, we we can have parents that are
concrete
files, anthropic skills, moose moose
skills, uh or just whatever
prototypes.
But we can also inherit from abstract
concepts like love or more concretely,
uh Microsoft COM IUnknown or uh the uh
Google GCS
file access API or a function that
returns a pointer to an array of
strings, okay? So, so we can inherit
from single words that name something
like the name of a library or the name
of a you know, the name of something
that's well-documented in the training
data is what it matters.
Or, we can even have even looser natural
language inheritance like I inherit from
a taco with crispy shell and hot meat
and vegetables overflowing and sauces,
okay?
You know, maybe I'm making I'm defining
a new
food, but it wants this particular type
of taco I can describe in a few words
as a parent
and then we'll start from there. So, um
but you know, mixing in
literally different types of inheritance
from a very concrete thing to something
that's in the training data. Okay, that
you only have to ask uh by name. Kay
Loden.
Um anyway, where were we? So, they're in
the training data.
You can inherit a whole language, a
protocol, another object system. You can
inherit object systems. Like, when I'm
defining the Mu object system, I want to
inherit Self's object system just by
saying
one of my parents is Self's object
system. And another of my parents is US
patent number 1 2 3 4 5 filed by David
Rosenthal and Owen Dinsmore
about how to convert a file system into
and the shell and paths into an
executable tree of objects. Okay? So,
you can inherit by referring to a US
patent. Okay? And hopefully that
patent's expired or it's in your name,
or you might have legal troubles, but
fortunately
the Rosenthals and Dinsmore's patent is
expired. So, um so that and it helps to
have some naming discipline.
And uh failure modes, graceful
degradation. So,
anyway, so there was an interesting uh
Hacker News discussion about YouTrackDB.
And I think versus is too hard a word. I
mean,
I want to inherit from YouTrackDB the
great things about it
and build on top of it. I'm not saying
this is an alternative to it. They're
very different.
But, uh
YouTrackDB, JetBrains class-based object
oriented graph DB. And we
compare in order to inherit what each is
better at.
And the machine language movie, you see,
you this is like Java VM executes it,
but we're being executed by an LLM.
However, we'll get to this later, this
Dublin Core thing.
We do want to have kind of a a machine
executable core.
So, um
we can make adapters, bridges, and
emulators to different object systems.
Anybody any Python programmer that has
used
like uh
PiGTK knows that it has a G object
wrapper for GTK's object system to like
bring that into Python.
And or or like SWIG to plug a
library or a library that just happens
to have an object system
into Python and make bridges so that you
can subclass objects defined in another
uh object system. So, all this has been
done with like C and C++ and stuff.
Uh but we are purposefully doing it in
the LLM execution engine virtual
machine. So, the LLMs can just like
imagine virtual machines and then be
them. So, um I mean, they are. Uh so,
live object examples. Okay, so we have
like
we're we're using these for actual
things and we're learning from them.
Ground Up uh software is my my company
and that's how we do it from the ground
up or like hamburger
or or or used coffee beans. But, um so,
the system is running in public. So,
Soul City
Micropolis core, Soul's content human
LLM collaboration, and Adventure 4 is a
built-in world world example.
So, Dublin core and the Adventure
compiler
the strict machine executable core under
the rich semantic overlay. Natural
language guards compiled to guard JS by
an LLM resolving linter warnings.
Instance first, not yet lifted the
the good, not the evil racist, but the
good creative Scott Adams lineage who
made Scott Adams Adventureland on the
TRS-80 and Apple II.
So, now I have a new buzzword for you.
Uh
humansplaining.
Its meaning is obvious. It's like the
the
complement the other direction of AI
slop. So, the named anti-pattern wasting
tokens telling an LLM what it already
need knew knows. AI slop's mirror image
the skill script case study capability
confinement begin belongs in the runtime
not the grammar. So, we'll get into
humansplaining but then I'll provide a
annotated bibliography. Every YAML
source cited by this series annotated is
human readable prose with links back to
the live files. One ladle from the Repos
cream layer. See, ladle is a a K line
that refers
to
the cauldron skill. So, we'll get to
that later, too. But, okay, reading
order. First, read about Self and Moo
latent space inheritance the case
studies the annotated bibliography is
the side table consulted with a citation
points in the YAML and you don't want to
context switch. So, the heritage 1980s
Self Ungar and Smith 1987. Clone
override delegate is the risk core that
everything lowers to.
Source Smalltalk in a risk Ungar and
Patterson and Sequoin Berkeley '83 to
'85. Smalltalk in a risk the minimal
primitive discipline Self grew from.
Lisp machine flavors to Common Lisp
class to meta object protocol MOP.
Howard Cannon Moon Bob Rao Kickzales et
cetera mixins method combinations
multiple dispatch open implementations
before and after the events and around.
So, news TNT the news toolkit HyperLook
inspired by HyperCard. Um
this
is
a like well, it was a shipping window
system
a shipping
user
end user user interface construction and
editing system like HyperCard and then a
shipping game SimCity on top of all of
So, Owen Densmore, James Gosling, David
Rosenthal, me, Don Hopkins, Arthur van
Hoff, who like ended up after that
writing the Java compiler in Java, etc.
So, it used multiple inheritance object
oriented PostScript, which inspired by
Smalltalk, of course. Uh shipped as a
system software, HyperCard like editable
scriptable UI, and SimCity as live
objects that you could like deconstruct
the game's user interface and build it
back. So, Owen Densmore and Rosenthal
then after doing the News object
oriented system realized see News took
Smalltalk's objects and implemented it
on what PostScript was already doing,
which includes a dictionary stack for
looking up names, which is all you need
like, you know, attention is all you
need. We would say dictionary stack,
PostScript dictionary stack is all you
need to implement multiple inheritance
PostScript. And guess what that's
isomorphic to? A shell path
within a file system. So, you can do
objects.
This is what this patent is about, okay?
So,
um
boom, you know, this like see we can
inherit from this This is a K-line
to
this patent that explains everything,
okay?
This is it right here. Um
so,
Gary Drescher, um he was Marvin Minsky's
graduate student. He made Made Up Minds
in 1991, and that inspired us at Lila
AI, who who Henry Minsky is my colleague
and the CTO, uh Marvin's son, of course,
to do a schema mechanism. The LL Okay,
we hit a
the wall was in Lisp or Python is that
there's no grounding, no way to do
grounding, right? Well, guess what LLM
does really well. So, anyway, earlier
back Minsky has written about K lines,
which I think I touched on, and then
especially Society of Mind, which we are
This gives you a much better perspective
and way to frame and collocate agents in
the same LLM call. Not having a whole
bunch of agents
talking to each other by serializing and
deserializing pay per token like
it's like prisoners in solitary
confinement
exchanging notes by writing in in
lipstick on wet napkins and then sending
them back and forth with carrier pigeons
instead of having everyone in the same
room together, okay? The distortion and
the cost caused by serializing and
deserializing like high-dimension vector
pointers to ideas
the the noise that you're introducing
and the the
climate change that you're that you're
perpetrating just for doing that
incredibly inefficient thing when you
could just put put them together and
they just like point to each other's
ideas in the same LLM call you know, GPU
memory, okay? So
applying Society of Mind to LLMs, there
are like
really good ideas that you can do to
make it much more efficient. Uh
not just efficient, but like be able to
do things you couldn't do before. So,
the activation mechanism and the agency
model
agency composed of multiple agents that
can communicate efficiently, you know,
like telepathically, okay? I mean,
literally, they're in the same
spark of of
if you would call it consciousness or
not, it doesn't matter. They're in the
same LLM completion call
in the same context. Uh the whole thing
runs on Okay, and now here's where
getting retro.
COM O laying ActiveX, multiple
interfaces per object. See, Java had to
like a
Self inspired Java and JavaScript, but
they
made crippled implementations of it. And
I mean, they all had their own design
trade-offs and shall we say time
constraints.
Uh but, Java doesn't use multiple
inheritance of implementation. It
separates that out into and and so does
C#. Into interfaces that don't have
implementation. So, you can multiply
inherit interfaces and then it's up to
you to implement those interfaces behind
the scene. C++ supplies this.
COM is simply looking at C++ multiple
inheritance, V tables, objects that have
multiple interfaces having a sequence of
V table pointers, and then query
interface casting a pointer between
these pointers to the V table pointers.
And then and then query interface being
the first
function in the V table allowing you to
pivot between interfaces, right? This is
a great idea as as as horribly as it was
like where it led, I didn't even put
DCOM into here because that's where it
gets really grizzly.
But, um there's some great ideas in
there.
Um
So, uh
That's my cat's meowing.
But, anyway, query interface
translates to just is there
a foo.yaml file in this directory
that
declares and implements the foo
interface and could contain any
state that foo might need it, but you
also have the entire directory for
shared states like the C++ concrete
implementation class behind the facade
of multiple interfaces. So,
um anyway, so skills implementing this.
We've got a lot of skills. See, these
are moom skills. Prototype
is the moom skill
that defines how you can use
directories, objects, and files, and
skills themselves as prototypes for
other
directories and classes if you Classes
are just something you can implement
with prototypes when treating them a
certain way. An object, this is the
object system with definition within the
object system.
Uh artifactory
is the idea of objects that make other
objects and protocols that they can
follow and how they relate to these
other skills. Skill, the meta skill,
skill skill. Everybody's got a skill
skill.
I mean, Anthropic even has a skill for
how to make Anthropic skills, but these
are not These are more than Anthropic
skills. So, there's a lot of stuff in
this skill skill here.
Um file system object.
Like I've explained that. K-lines,
society of mind, incarnation is a
protocol for creating characters richly
and ethically. And uh
there's character, of course, and then
empathic templates
are instead of like mustache templates
with a certain syntax,
you just explain to the LLM what you
want it to fill in. I mean,
why why run I mean, you're if you're
running it through an LLM, why also run
it through some very limited uh
template system. So,
uh and schema mechanism is Gary
Drescher's schema mechanism, and schema
factory goes with that. And then schema
Oh my god, schema is a hot topic here.
Leela AI is where I work with Henry
uh and now, see, schema is a very
general term. There are many different
types of schema. Schema
This is worth just hopping into. Um
schema
is a veritable schemapedia. An
encyclopedia
is a circle of general knowledge.
Consider this a schemy p- schemapedia. A
circle drawn around schema in every moom
since
that needs a name and a shelf. There's a
lot of different schemas and we're
trying to be
we're trying to catalog them all. So, or
at least the good ones. Not the W3C
listed ontology directory. They have
ontology repository catalog such as the
BioPortal and blah blah blah blah blah.
Okay. And there's an old schemapedia
thing out there that is not this. We're
just reusing the name.
Uh okay, but anyway, the idea here
is your schemas. What kind of schemas
are there? Mechanisms. Mechanisms was
like haha, look at this. Comex Pcom
cursor mirror data set, pressure, get
GitHub JSON schema key lines, mechanism,
Minsky frame, Postgres, Relax NG, self
self, shell orchestration, society minus
QL SQL light. Plug your own schemas in.
Like we love Zod schemas.
So, why are why do we love them?
Schemapedia Zod argument. Okay. Ah,
wanted to introduce you to YAML jazz.
Now, this one doesn't have a comment a
lot of comments, but the point is that
you're you're you're just taking you
don't have a schema. You're you're
making up schemas from the ground up.
And if they're useful, then they
propagate and get copied. And then
later, you play, you learn, and then you
lift into formal schema definitions that
are usable and composable to other
schemas. So, these we just pulled these
out of our ass. In fact, LLMs are great
at pulling things out of his ass. But,
like pro- you just you can understand
this by reading it. But, so can the LLM.
And the other thing that we don't see
here
are like comments. End of line comments
saying
like, why did I set this to this? What
was what was it before? And then also,
you can have multi-line comments of any
number of lines. It's like
arbitrarily high bandwidth out of band
overlay of semantic information that
humans and LLMs can read and write. So,
in general, you don't you want your
tools to preserve comments because
comments are precious. But, anyway, I
digress. Let's go back to Z and
mechanisms and So, that this
this is a skill
all about [snorts] schemas in general,
schema mechanisms.
And
now it's just knowledge that we can draw
from and be inspired from and refer to
with paths. This is very concrete
instead of just abstract K-lines cuz
See, if I just go and I say data set
well, that like
obviously, you can Google for it and you
can read why it's so cool.
But
now we've like reified it into our our
concrete thing and you know, formally
defined that it is named this and how it
works and where you can go to get more
information. So, that's what we're doing
here.
But, anyway, I digress.
Um
Uh let's see. Did we get to the end? No,
we were just on Oh, my god. So, um
schema Lila AI, we do neurosymbolic
AI.
We do uh manufacturing intelligence and
uh real-time computer vision and but
then with a layer
I mean, computer vision is like the
the neat AI, the mathematically
you know, it's a black box. It's fuzzy.
We don't know how or why it works, but
we do not know from whence they come.
But, we neurosymbolically AI layers and
sandwiches and mixes in symbolic AI of
the you know, the old school
uh fuzzy See, uh
it's like
physics
uh
like versus biology, okay? See, physics
can be explained with mathematics, but
biology is all exceptions and ad hoc
rules. That's kind of the fuzzy AI
versus neat AI distinction. But, uh the
conclusion that when they had all these
discussions back when they coined those
terms, is that we need both. And they're
they're both good for things that the
other isn't.
So, anyway, the kernel directory is
objects selfish common implementation I
touched on.
And we have like a constitution, you
know, like lean into the training. Don't
make up like Gastown for no
reason. We'll get into that. So, prior
design selfish influence, Garnet Amulet
Prototype System I work with Brad Myers
CMU and and and CMU Common Lisp, of
course, on a user interface system that
used constraints using the KR knowledge
representation system and
Lisp could like parse your expressions,
figure out what they depended on, and
automatically wire up a dependency
network, and do um it actually used a
pull constraints. So, when you need it,
you read it and recompute it if anything
it depends on has changed. Where like
Open Laszlo uses push because that was
more efficient to implement in the Flash
engine. So, Garnet and Open Laszlo were
prototypes for reactive programming,
which React claimed, but all React is is
iterating on DOM shadow. No reaction,
no reactive programming, no constraint
tracking. While Svelte comes along,
especially Svelte 5, and actually
ships a reactive system in the spirit of
Garnet and Open Laszlo.
Um but so, prototype
fragment config directory is I and known
Moo heritage from Lambda Moo, Pavel
Curtis's work in Xerox PARC. And
Linguistic Motherboard was John
Warnock's invention and intention for
PostScript, where it's just a
motherboard for plugging in cards, and
the first card he plugged in was
graphics, you know, stencil paint,
printer duff,
graphics rendering to a bitmap to print.
But, there's also like a networking
card, and there's Now, we've got a like
an LLM inference card, and you know, so
But, the idea that he when when Owen
Densmore worked at Apple, he was making
Apple's printing system.
And he went over
to
Adobe and worked with
with, you know, all these people at
Adobe uh
to understand what the hell they were
doing with PostScript, and how can we
make that supported by the Mac operating
system.
And develop a product like the
LaserWriter that revolutionized
desktop printing and publishing.
So,
he got this idea of the linguistic
motherboard, and then he went to Sun,
and James Gosling took a step back and
looked at all the window systems and
said like, how can we make a window
system that sends code instead of
commands, a limited command set like X
windows.
And then Owen saw this, and it's
PostScript. PostScript is like Lisp
crossed with Forth, but more Lisp than
Forth because it's
like it's data is is polymorphic
arrays and dictionaries, exactly the
same as JSON.
Okay, instead of like typed binary crap
that Forth, I mean, I love Forth, but
it's very low-level, okay. PostScript
it In one page of code, Owen implemented
a Smalltalk-like class system,
object-oriented programming system, on
top of which we built user interface
tool kits, applications,
even HyperLook, several versions,
HyperGoodNews, HyperNews, HyperLook.
There was like other things between
there, but you know, user editable
environments
out of this object system that was just
like
designed to run on a PostScript
interpreter. It also ran on the printer.
I have like really cool pictures.
So, um and then also we draw from the
lineage of visual programming. I don't
even get me started. But
uh anyway, so this is broken up
into This is just the readme.
Uh and I will go over the uh rest of the
stuff next.